hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action on leeches I've already
played a couple of games but I still
don't have a rating I have to play 20 of
them as I have been informed so nicely
in the comments and tomorrow I have a
classical game in the cretian chess
league with my chess club so it's a good
preparation so let's uh up this to 10
minutes and let's find an
opponent uh so last game we lost it was
U pretty pretty unfortunate we had a
nice Evans Gambit position but uh we
lost and here let me just uh click out
of the Zen mode we are facing uh
Mora Morada moru from Egypt and he goes
for D4 and we're going to play this uh
like I would approach a normal classical
game so I always play Knight F6 to D4
and I uh I don't mind playing the Nimo
Indian so if he wants to play that we're
going to play that okay so we have the
Nimo and now it all depends on what he
plays will it be like a queen C2 E3 A3
okay Queen C2 and and uh we're going to
Castle so castles and standard moves
like D5 C5 and get our Queen side pieces
into the game uh all right
D5 uh probably E3 is coming at some
point okay so he goes for uh this nice
Bishop maneuver and we're going to what
do we do
H let just get the Knight into the game
with we defend
here okay so I usually play with C5 so
I'm going to play with C5
now so it's a strong Bishop but I don't
think we need to
worry all right and Bishop here and now
we're going to play H6 just to get um
distension out of the
way okay and uh yeah rookie one rookie
eight sorry Rook e 8 or do we go B6
first am I am I in a rush to play
B6 yeah Rook e one uh
yeah let's uh let's stop E4 for the
moment yeah once he castles we're going
to have to capture otherwise our E4 Pawn
is very
vulnerable sorry the the D5 Pawn uh my
my bad uh and now we're just going to
play D do I have time for B6 that's
always a question
here yeah I guess we
do I guess we
do yeah if we if we can develop our
light Square Bishop then everything is
fine okay so now he obviously uh he
wants to stop Bishop to B7 because if I
play Bishop to B7 he takes my knight and
then if I take with the queen he can
mess up my Pawn structure here uh on the
other hand uh what can can we do huh
what can we do if we don't do
that yeah we can play G5 I don't know if
G5 is even an option here because he
will be able to attack my king but uh
I'm pretty sure that it's
okay and then after he plays this I'm
going to go Bishop to B7 so I get my
development but he did weaken my king
side a
bit
uh it's actually much better than I
hoped for uh
uh okay that's a pretty pretty standard
idea which doesn't really bother me all
that much so we're just going to play
Rook to
C8 yeah our Knight is nicely guarding
the Knight and the Knight on
D7 so let's uh get the Rook to C8 and
now he'll
probably either develop his Rooks
or
or he might even play something like
Queen to D3 I don't know to get out of
the Rook uh rook's range on C8 and then
maybe even go for a bishop to A6 but I
doubt it I seriously doubt it although I
know that if he manages to trade his
light score Bishop on on A6 then my
pawns on the queen side will be somewhat
weak so we'll see what it does we're
doing okay on time he's a little bit
better um
yeah
if I don't blunder anything big this
should be fairly
[Music]
solid all right so probably he just gets
the Rooks into the game no reason to to
postpone
development and uh yeah
huh we should get this uh Rook out of
the
pin okay that's uh that's
interesting interesting to say the
least if C4 okay he does get this
diagonal for his Queen do we do we care
about that I mean it's a very
anti-position move to play I pawn to C4
I'm just checking if it's maybe uh okay
to play it
tactically yeah and if we attack the
bishop he might
trade yeah let's attack the
bishop I don't want to I don't want to
rush it with C4 and I don't I don't
really think it's a good move okay so we
take
here uh
and we blunder our Pawn while we're at
it of
course yeah a little bit only a little
bit
huh yeah we blunder our Pawn but we get
I I I could play C4 I could play C4 but
I could also give up the pawn for uh for
compensation on the second Rank and
that's exactly what we'll do
he will take the pawn I will take here
and claim the second rank for
myself uh yeah
okay oh yeah oh yeah the the H6 Pawn was
hanging as well well better get all the
blunders out of the way uh so I don't
commit any
tomorrow all right let's Let's uh put
the Rook on the G
file and uh let's grab hold of the no
let's capture here
once he does have pressure here so we're
going to get pressure or do I want to
give up this Pawn as well first I'm
going to play this yeah he he will have
one check if I don't do anything
uh yeah let's go here this at least
stops him from uh moving his Bishop
anywhere
so he's up by a lot of
Pawns not a lot okay he's up two pawns
which is
fine just have to figure out a way uh
all right so if I take here obviously he
just plays Rook
here which uh yeah okay you can play
like I take he goes here I play Queen
here uh which kind of forces the trade
but also it allows him yeah I can't move
the queen F7 is hanging
h
[Music]
but I I could take both of his pawns
yeah it does sort of get him back into
the game oh but also takes Rook C7 huh
Rook C7 is what you want to do but what
about takes Rook C7 I play this and then
he takes my queen and I play Rook
captures here he goes here I play Rook
captures here with check he can block
with the
Rook although H it is possible it is
possible but is it is it
anything yeah if I push the pawn he's
just going to push this Pawn also also
very
nice
not bad at all not bad at all all right
so we're we're burning a lot of time
here but if I don't find this move it's
lost
so uh I I have to invest I have to
invest in this
move
H I see nothing
better okay now we'll see now we'll see
what is happening so can I just push and
allow Rook C7 Queen E4 no he takes here
I move my king and I get checkmated so
we don't want that to happen definitely
not what else can we
do
we can just play a slow
move yeah slow move H not the best not
the best but I need to survive until I
open up this
diagonal he's much better on time okay
so obviously he gives a nice check he
wants to get the bishop here which uh of
course he should that's the best
move yeah but if he does that I I can
even play six so I I I do survive a
little
bit or n no
okay yeah so objectively I'm pretty sure
he's completely winning here uh but
we're going to we're going to try we're
banking everything on opening this uh
this diagonal okay so he does play that
very nice very nice and very
interesting so now if I just block with
the Rook what what was his plan que
here and then we play Queen here yeah
he's not allowing us to open up this
diagonal he's being very tricky about it
so F6 while it is nice uh you know they
do say that F6 loses pretty much all the
positions and here he can even yeah then
gets the D6 Square oh this is uh not the
best not the best
definitely
huh yeah we got to do it we got to do it
otherwise we just get mated so he will
go Queen to D6 and offer a trade I will
be able to avoid a trade because of the
Checkmate threat on G4 and then he'll go
back Bishop to G3 and then we have to
figure out what's what otherwise we just
uh otherwise we just
resign well that's pretty much all we
have oh yeah that's what we were
expecting so not really
uh not really a surprise or
anything yeah and if B goes back we can
even can
we can we do
it
H Rook G6
Now sort of Keeps Us in the
game maybe just a little
bit yeah of course he will play that and
we're going to go here he does have this
check although I don't know how useful
it is he still has to get his Rook into
the game
somehow we're getting very low on time
oh he's just crushing us here but we're
still being very
annoying we're being very annoying and
this is a problem now if he doesn't uh
come up with a
threat so like I said he will block but
then we at least get a pass Pawn maybe
something's happening
here or I also have to be careful about
Rook captures and C6 maybe he has some
checks that he can combine but uh for
the moment while the at least while the
Pawn's here yeah if I push the pawn he
might even have this Rook captures Rook
captures and then Queen checks picks up
the Rook yeah hm that's uh not the best
not the
best uh but also yeah if the Rook
captures I might have an in between
check which forces his King into the
open and we might be able to be extra
annoying
there yeah okay he does that obviously I
go uh I go to a light Square we don't
want to get uh checked by the
bishop and here uh if I push and he okay
so Queen here obviously he's not going
to allow the push as he
shouldn't uh do we have any anything
now so we can make a rook lift but then
it's uh it's it's problematic
yeah very
problematic this bishop is an excellent
Defender that that is
true so we go here put pressure on this
Pawn he's it's it's not likely that he
will ever move the Bishop from G3 and
I'm I'm down to 30 seconds so I really
don't have uh better better
options yeah okay so he somehow gets his
Rook into the game we'll go
here there's probably a very devious
Checkmate for him somewhere okay so he
goes here is there is there something
here okay we
can no we can't we can't
unfortunately I'm going to try one less
trick Rook F6 maybe he takes my
queen no I want to Checkmate him
no no yeah sure sure you can take back
no he he's doing it again
okay okay so there there we go all right
so we lost this one uh pretty
hard uh so let's just check uh let's
just check the game and see where where
why did we have such huge problems
developing okay so this is all fine this
is all fine this is fine this is fine
this is uh yes C4 for some reason reason
yeah C4 is the the top move here yeah it
just forces the bishop off of the strong
diagonal but I don't know uh good to
know but I thought it was very anti-p
positional okay so castles castles I
captured okay everything is fine here
yeah knight5 okay or maybe instead of B6
C4 okay so no B6 fine G5 okay C4
preferred but G5 not
terrible uh yeah okay so here Knight E4
is the move yeah
it's the move that I almost always play
against the the Nimo Indian especially
in classical uh but here I was just
burning too much time Bishop B7 so yeah
uh like I said if I can play Bishop to
B7 without it being losing uh I I'll be
fine but yeah okay Rook ad D1 he he
played Bishop to B5 instead Rook C8 okay
Queen to B3 A6 this is now now I kind of
equalized the Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures and B6 uh oh
Rook e six
first okay yeah makes sense yeah don't
blunder the H6 Point yeah H6 was the was
the big blunder of my position that kind
of made it unplayable yeah okay Queen
here did I have any counterplay or was
it all yeah okay we captures
captures yeah nothing to be done here
yeah he didn't make any mistakes okay so
here he even had the queen captur on
F7 uh oh so this was a blunder by him
and I called his blunder but no oh
because of Queen captures an
E3 ah okay but yeah I was I was too low
on time to even see that I I can
actually win a pawn and go into Bishops
of opposite colors H nice yeah and here
he just plays this queen C2 still holds
huh yeah very nice okay now now it's uh
pointless to continue but yeah uh it was
uh you know not terrible up until Bishop
to B7 too optimistic uh you know with
Knight to E4 it's still in the in the
spirit like of of the NSO Indian uh but
after Bishop to B7 is just objectively
lost uh so yeah well he did give me one
chance to get back into the game I
missed it and it was a very nice victory
for him so good job Mr Morad Yu 1573 uh
very nicely done and hopefully uh I will
play better tomorrow in in in the the
classical game that I have for my chess
club uh so there we have it hope you
enjoyed uh I will see you soon and uh
you know uh learn your
openings